happy deathday reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna
watch the trailer for happy deathday to
you I'm excited to check this trailer
out Papes before we do that it's the end
of the month so I wanted to say thank
you to everyone who has been following
us over at patreon over there we do
weekly Q&A s which are a total blast
plus we do TV show reaction watch along
for many a shows that includes anime
such as Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
attack on Simon my hero academia
live-action shows like Gotham Riverdale
and Supernatural and John does plenty a
music video coverage during the week as
well and just as a heads up like most of
our videos we review the trailers right
after we are done shooting our reaction
for it but because it's universal and
the way they work with us on YouTube
we're gonna have to do this on two
separate videos don't worry we don't do
this for most of them but for universal
more often than not we will have to if
it annoys you that you have to click on
another video I'm sorry for the hard
labor you have to do for the free video
you're watching really put upon and I
really apologize for the stress that it
causes you there was any way we can fix
this anyway let's watch the trailer hit
him today
I yes potato reset when you died right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I I have a lot more thoughts than I
was expecting
I thought it was just gonna be like well
it looks cool it looks fun we're doing
this again buddy but I'm like oh it
actually feels like there's plenty to
talk about oh well you guys can hop on
to our trailer review for that I'm sure
there's a link right here look at the
pin comment or something like that but
yeah thank you guys for watching and
we'll see you on the next little video
right now if you carry your thoughts